moi c'est alex la jolie petite blonde
c'est sandra valentin toutes les nanas
virtuel mais quéréel ses nouveaux hôtes
à inventer un truc quand je préfère
étudier observe reculer pour mieux
sauter ça c'est sûr toi toi tu veux tu
recules beaucoup et il sait pas grand
chose à moi aussi la presse que 20 ans
étaient très amoureux de monica valentie
la maire de cendras
car ça n'a jamais eu aucune chance
d'habiter souvent antoine chanoine je
n'ai pas parlé d'une affaire extrêmement
important soit bref promis tout d'abord
laissez-moi vous dire quel plaisir
j'avoue par les plus brefs ok alors en
faisant des bois chiffons amoureux jour
des plus jolies filles de la région
je viens télé mais après tu disparais et
puis sous amphètes préfère être plus
haut j'ai une expérience malheureuse
avec une cousine cousine ou enfin il
paraît éloignée 1 la fille du frère de
ma mère
sa cousine et sinon vous êtes sur
twitter
pourquoi quand vous connaissez plus tard
je connais le crétois donc tu crois que
le canada exhorte au menton je pêche de
rentrer 3 gueule à dire des trucs
s'il te plaît change de look et fait
quelque chose les survêtements ta coupe
de choses euros
tu vas ou à 7 heures du matin bah je
vais courir dans cette tenue temps ça
suffit clichés du mec qui comptent
forcément au jogging au nom tout aussi
bien comme ça
coton bio fiscaux
pour vincent bru tournure 6
gj m'a appris tout ce que le 7e me
remerciez pas c'est qu'il s'agit mais
c'est pas lui qui gît dans l'autre c'est
la petite fille à battre eh bien moi je
prends la petite fille j alors trop
inexpérimenté trop jeune et alex pour
twitter
votre fils contrat du vin pas mon fils
tu as ton père tu vois